what's up everyone this is Anthony pop
Leon Oh most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off
Perry an boring is the founder and
president of the chamber of digital
commerce the world's leading blockchain
trade association in this conversation
we discussed the current state of crypto
regulation the roles of the SEC CFTC
FinCEN and others the biggest potential
concerns in Washington DC around crypto
regulation and what you at home can do
to help organizations like the chamber
of digital commerce be more effective I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you do as well all right guys bang
bang I am here with Perry Anne we've got
a whole bunch of [ __ ] to talk about
you probably sit in one of the most
interesting seats in the crypto industry
because you deal with over 200 different
companies and members at the chamber
digital commerce so thanks so much for
coming and doing this yeah thanks for
having me it's it's been a amazing year
and I think 2020 is gonna be remarkable
can we say it's been an amazing year in
2020 if we're ready we were recording to
something like the 6th or 7th of January
or do we have to say last year was an
amazing year I think this year has
already been here
bring crypto time remember alright fair
fair fair let's start with your
background I think you come from a whole
different world than most people in
crypto just give us kind of an overview
and then how you got into Bitcoin
blockchain cryptocurrencies yes so my
background is in public policy my
biggest passion is monetary policy how
money works and how its regulated I got
into crypto when I was working on
Capitol Hill so I worked for a member of
the Financial Services Committee I went
to DC to really fight for a better
economic future for my generation and
those that will come after me I grew up
in Florida and the financial crisis was
really devastating to really anybody in
Florida and my community and I was
actually studying economics at the
University of Florida during the
financial crisis there kind of a
historic moment to really dig into what
was happening all around me and I was
very frustrated because my professors
could not explain what was happening in
real time in our economy and actually
Ron Paul was running for president he
was the only person who could make any
sense of what was happening and what I
learned through that was quite
disturbing just the amount of debt and
the deficits and I just the lack of
transparency and basic basic ethics in
our financial system was quite upsetting
and so at a young age I just dedicated
my career to economic policy and and for
fighting for something better so that
took me to the White House I was an
intern at the White House what's that
like um that was really surreal
I wish president President Obama I was
there right after he was brought into
office and right at I was there during
the bailouts and so I was in the
National Economic Council when Larry
Summers was running that and part of my
job as an intern was tracking all the
stimulus funds which I was adamantly
against so it was it was interesting to
be and in the middle of that but to come
from you know very small town in Florida
and say you know I want to work on
economic policy and I want to fight for
something better and then within you
know less than a year I find myself in
the middle of the White House you know
in the National Economic Council that's
making these decisions I had this huge
impression on me and it really what came
out of that was that you can do anything
you want you can do anything you set
your mind to and and you know the first
african-american president it was just
you know it was such an empowering thing
for me to get to experience that of
someone who didn't come from like a
super wealthy family or you know a
family that was well-connected in
politics but to get to have that
experience as a young person was just
really amazing so after the White House
went to Capitol Hill or for a member of
Congress in the House of Representatives
and
you know was there during dodd-frank and
advising on all issues impacting
economics and financial services and
then I learned about Bitcoin so I was
working on the JOBS Act and one of my
friends is like look if you're excited
about crowdfunding you should really
look into this thing called Bitcoin and
you know hurt friend yeah yeah and I
yeah I owe them my career at this point
but you know the idea that there's a
currency that's not controlled by a
government or a group of people or a
corporation that it's you know it's open
and it's transparent
that was just an unbelievably
fascinating idea to me so I quickly fell
into a rabbit hole I'm still in that
rabbit hole but what came out of that is
you know I think this technology is the
most important thing I'll see in my
entire lifetime
and I really wanted to be a part of this
space and so I spent some time really
thinking about what do I have to offer
how can I help build this community and
of course my background is in public
policy and what exactly is public policy
like everyone hears that word but if you
don't come out of the government
Washington DC like that whole kind of
culture and industry I don't think
people really know it's like we don't
think of public pulse like what is that
well the the policies overseeing laws
and regulations but the process on how
laws are made the legislative process
that's an incredibly important thing to
understand because you can spend a lot
of time running all over Capitol oil and
not get anything done I know how how can
you be effective in those roles and
you're working with the the agencies the
regulators and then also the courts
affect policy as well as someone who had
worked on Capitol Hill and you know my
job was to meet with all the special
interest groups all the lobbyists and
the lawyers and it was lobbied on all
sorts of issues involving banking and
finance and I you see a lot of very
disturbing things people who have all
sorts of terrible motives things that
can be very destructive for for the
people who are gonna be impacted by
these laws and regulations so I really
wanted to build something that could one
stand the test of time but
two could not be manipulated or
controlled by a group or an organization
or people that may have motives that are
not Pro the growth of crypto and
blockchain for sure um so that's why we
are a nonprofit organization so how did
you cope with the idea for the chamber
so I 2013 was the year that I was
studying and trying to decide you know
how do we want to do this and how do we
want to build it and I really spent that
year studying nonprofit law anyway I
wanted to set up a nonprofit but what
kind of nonprofit how do you do it
and that was also kind of the year of
bitcoins first international coming-out
party I guess so you know the first
thing was Cyprus was going through their
bailout in the European Union and people
started buying Bitcoin because it was an
uncertain economic environment and that
was pretty cool and the price of Bitcoin
went way up because they got these
international headlines and it was
really the first time that Bitcoin as an
alternative currency actually proved to
work and so that was pretty cool and
exciting but then there were some
not-so-great things that happened that
year you had Silk Road which was a
massive black eye to the industry and
then of course Mount Cox which I
shouldn't have happened but you know
also a huge PR nightmare for this
community and as someone who was living
and working in DC and really you know
how yeah you can see how regulators and
lawmakers can read a headline and that's
kind of their first impression and their
understanding and how that can be a
problem for us so in the early days of
this space you know most people in
Washington just thought Bitcoin was
literally like the currency for drug
dealers had like no idea these amazing
companies were behind this there were
companies building this technology for
positive things and that that is a
recipe for disaster
someone should tell about the dollar
[Laughter]
yeah I'm putting that into perspective
it certainly can be a fun mental
exercise to go through all right so you
say hey look I want to start a
non-profit you basically spent 2013
studying all the nonprofit law trying to
figure out what is the right structure
how do you want to do it etc what what
kind of the first steps when you got
started you just create the entity and
then go out to a bunch of companies and
say hey do you want to be a part of this
like how did it work originally yeah and
in those days we launched in July of
2014 so we're about 5 and a half years
old today
that was a really different era in
crypto for those who were around back
then there's not that many who are in
the 5 year Club but it was you know
public companies were at least admitting
we know now there is lots and lots of
companies that were investing all sorts
of R&D in this space but you know the
banks hadn't come out yet we weren't
even using the word blockchain back then
used Bitcoin with a big B to represent
the protocol for those who may be
experimenting with other things but and
also that community was very you know
the early community was very libertarian
kind of you know anti-government
anti-regulation and so then we came out
it's like yo we actually think we should
be engaging with regulators and so I
wasn't quite sure what kind of response
we were gonna get and I'll never forget
when we announced the chamber I did it
at a a conference a Bitcoin conference
in Chicago and I was like you know these
people are gonna try to like kill me or
like maybe they'll think it's cool but
so far so good but we launched with
about 15 founding members and it was
really those two scandals of Silk Road
and Mount GOx where you had legitimate
businesses who said look this is not
good for our business to have these
types of things out there in the news it
is important that we have professionals
and experts who can work with lawmakers
to help them understand and clear up
misconceptions that they may have seen
or read but also help guide them in
their jobs as policymakers and make sure
that the laws really do take into
account the unique characteristics of
this technology
and that the laws are going to foster
innovation not prevent it yeah how much
of what you guys do is education versus
like hey you shouldn't create this law
rights like the more like lobbying type
stuff versus let us help you understand
how the technology works and like why
this is important cetera yeah I mean the
first several years of the chamber it
was pretty much all education and that's
still a huge part of what we do and a
big part of how we're spending our time
is is one being that resource making
sure that we are talking to the right
offices or working with with agencies
that have jurisdiction over this space
and making sure the people who are in
charge of this topic have the right
information so that that's a huge it
continues to be so a big part of the job
which makes sense to do that through a
trade association because it would be
incredibly expensive for any one company
to you know hire handful people in DC
just to make sure all the relevant
people in DC understand this space but
if we collectively if all these
companies can come together and share in
the Chamber's resources we all get to
benefit from that and it's a much more
effective way to educate the policy
community yeah I talked about on the
podcast before I went on my infamous
trip to DC yeah I spent two days there
and I walked away with my head spinning
I was like what the hell is this place
just in the sense of the way that things
worked the various types of people who
work at the different organizations the
different kind of legislators offices
how information gets shared across all
these different people and then how
things get done right kind of by
building consensus and really I think
being patient which is very different
than most technology technologists or
innovators are used to and so what have
you seen as like the positives right as
you guys have done this work do you see
a lot of these regulators and lawmakers
being like oh you know what like I now
understand and they're actually changing
their perspective or do you see them
kind of fighting this Ike what's the
respect
have been at this for you know five
years it's a funny question and yeah DC
is definitely a complicated organism but
I see has very different personalities
it wasn't that long ago that we did a
briefing for the the SEC who you know
the the industry's best friend at this
point it's been a lot of time they're
doing their job
right they're doing their job all right
I'm cool with the SEC yeah they haven't
done anything like there's other
countries where the regulator's have
stepped in and been complete you know
just heavy-handed Frankie done things
that have really really hurt people
trying to build right so they've
actively worked against it I think
what's happening here is the SEC is kind
of saying look we're not gonna change
anything yet right like we're still
trying to understand and to me like that
may slow people down but it's not anti
crypto regulations being passed as far
as I understand you you may think
differently of that yes so just even
just the attitudes of of the people
they're quite telling in terms of where
they are and and we as a resource to
them
you know we do on education for them but
thought hey you should probably be aware
of these things that are happening in
other places in DC's or from other
regulators and in Congress and things
that were seeing and in the industry
that you should be aware of and we're
here to be a resource to you to make
sure you you are informed but also we're
forming our opinions on some of these
things so we would also like to
understand your thoughts on this and and
and a lot of times you know those
conversations can get like a lot of
pushback looks like hey we're here to
help you like we this is not I think we
don't have to do this like we're here to
make sure you have the right information
and you're fully informed and in help
guide you in your thinking in that and
just just the the attitude again it's
quite telling it into where where they
are in this space and then you juxtapose
that with that same week we did a
similar briefing for a fencin you know
and their their job is to protect all
the financial system and
they are it's a completely different
attitude there you know you know go in
you know want to educate them hey we we
think you guys made a mistake here but
we want to point this out to you and
I'll show you how to correct it and they
were like so grateful thank you for this
information this is super helpful we
really appreciate it so it's it's you
kind of never know like where we're
where the pushback is gonna come from
but then when you do have a group or
agency who really wants to work together
and really wants to create that bridge
between the the policymaking community
and the industry it's really fulfilling
and when you can do you get meaningful
policy done in a way that's going to
support this industry it's worth it so
I'll give a shout-out to Cameron and
Tyler over at gemini this crypto need
regulation doesn't need rules okay or
can this thing hold the can this whole
thing happen without rules and without
the regulator's participating I mean
that's an interesting philosophical
debate I would say look the government
does exist and they have guns and they
can put you in jail so those are all
facts so it's better to help shape that
process and for it to be shaped around
you this is going to happen and that's a
you know a big thing we tell our members
is is there's regulators law enforcement
Congress that they're looking at this
they're scrutinizing this they are going
to impact the future of your business in
this industry and it's imperative that
we are at the table and that we have a
say in the direction that that that's
gonna look like for the future I
generally think there that makes sense
right it's like look whether you want it
or not
it just naturally they're going to do
something right it's almost like they
feel the need to do something whether
that's do a bunch of work and say hey we
the rules we have currently are good
enough or they come with new rules etc a
lot of its defense to a lot of times you
have groups trying to change the laws
and it's like wait no the laws work we
don't need to change them let's block
this from moving forward and that
there's a lot of things that people
never know that we do because we're
actually preventing things from
happening so you don't see it but it's
so that this gets into one of my
favorite topics and I don't think I've
actually ever talked about this publicly
but I'm really interested in the
propaganda Wars that go on and
in DC specifically if you think of
Bitcoin and crypto as like a financial
technology you know there's a lot of big
financial services firms a lot of
payment processors credit card companies
etc they probably want to see this
happen do you get any kind of sense that
like there's definitely the what I'll
call anti education right or kind of the
nefarious education of them pushing a
narrative that is hurtful to Bitcoin and
crypto in DC or how we not got to that
level yet where they they're so scared
of it or threatened by it that they're
starting to kind of do the anti lobbying
it's very possible it's very it's very
possible all there are some very
disingenuous things that we see we
suppose disingenuous one thing that
really really just gets under my skin is
these anti-money laundering arguments
where you have you know secretary the
Treasury secretary minutiae and gave you
know a speech from from the White House
saying you know we take you know anti
money laundering
seriously and terrorist financing
seriously in these virtual currencies
and Bitcoin you know their issues with
with with AML if that's really what
you're concerned about you should be so
excited it going because it is a
completely transparent radically
transparent system and if your job is to
follow the money we have actually given
you the best tool ever possible to do
that so it really that that type of
pushback is it's just kind of weird it's
like do you not did you let's break down
what he's saying right so do they take
anti money laundering and terrorist
financing seriously I actually think
that they do right like you know they
absolutely talk about something that
they definitely want to be on top of and
be the best in the world at I think the
question becomes that's your intention
it's really really hard with especially
physical cash right I think that's where
the big issues come in in the u.s.
dollar system if you're using the
banking system as long as the bank is
not being nefarious it's pretty easy to
identify money laundering or nefarious
activity right where I think the issues
show up is the thing like the dot dots
Bank and I think it was Estonia or
wherever where they're just laundering
money because there's
bad employees right there they're
empowering people to do this what should
be and I think what you're hinting at is
like bitcoin is a transparent immutable
ledger of transactions like literally
here is all the transactions you don't
have to subpoena the bank you know
anything that you just get all the
transactions the hard part to me in I'm
sitting in their seat is if you don't
understand how Bitcoin works very well
then you just look at it as oh we can't
tell what you you know who's who but
actually it works the same way right
they're still gonna be fiat on and
off-ramps they're still gonna be
identifiers zan etc and so it becomes
this cat-and-mouse game between
criminals and law enforcement but it to
your point I think law enforcement just
got a big step up in their abilities
because that transparent ledger is out
there for anyone to see right yeah no I
think the AML as a you know as a risk
for cryptocurrencies is not a legitimate
reason to not embrace this technology
because we have tools to address that
but yeah that also requires the you know
if law enforcement to do their jobs and
to learn a new technology and they have
and it's been a boon to law enforcement
somebody said to me good house a great
example they said it's like a car right
if somebody said hey criminals can use a
car to get away from bank robberies they
can breathe air should we ban the air
well well and on top of that they can
run somebody over in the crosswalk right
Internet they use computers all
technologies are going to be abused by
bad actors of course and so it doesn't
mean that you get rid of it it's just
that you make sure you understand how
they're gonna use it you try to use it
against them right to in order to to
capture them so epic sighs all right
let's talk about membership you guys
have what 220 members are so remember
200 companies so we are the first
blockchain trade association and and and
the largest about 40% of our members are
public companies we represent a number
of banks and financial institutions JP
Morgan Wells Fargo JP Morgan's in the
blockchain trade association and a
member of the chamber Jaime man what's
going on dude no I and
we also represent number of technology
companies like IBM Microsoft Cisco
consultancies like Accenture KPMG
Deloitte you know big companies that
have you know big practices exploring
and investing would it be fair to say
the big companies are the blockchain not
Bitcoin crowd uh some of them not all
some some of them I mean so there and
these are the people you know that that
we work with what a lot of them are very
Pro crypto but there's a lot of hurdles
to using and touching crypto in a highly
regulated environment so you know one of
the reasons why they're members of the
chamber is so they can understand how
the regulations apply to them and make
sure they have the tools that they need
to be able to innovate in this space and
then about 60% of our members are our
crypto companies and private companies
and startups so we represent a number of
the crypto exchanges custody providers
companies innovating with smart
contracts it really runs so I thought I
don't know if this something you guys
touch on but I saw an article I think
was today or yesterday that was talking
about cracking so Jesse over at Krakens
been super transparent and very vocal
about the the regulators are being I
want you to disrupt this far too strong
of a word but it's very costly to deal
with a lot of the subpoenas and and the
you know probes and things that were
there trying to get information we have
to have all these licenses and of course
the exchanges have to have licenses on a
state-by-state basis yeah
so you're maintaining that he says that
they spent over a million dollars right
last year yeah
the other one is block stack when they
went through their filing to do the
regulated token offering I think they
said they spent like two or three
million bucks right I mean these are
like legitimate costs for a business
especially a young business yeah how
much of the work you guys are doing is
trying to not even change the law or
keep the law the same but just share the
information right to me like if you're a
regulator and you're sitting there and
you're realizing hey we're putting a
pricey a pretty high price and a pretty
high burden on these companies I don't
know if I'd necessarily change my
behavior but it's a good data point to
understand like this is what the
company's going through it's almost kind
of a little bit in their shoes to
understand if you're a young
entrepreneur a young meaning the company
is young it's hard to build a business
if you're spending millions of dollars
dealing with regulations and things like
that yeah absolutely absolutely
I certainly feel for for small companies
who want to innovate in this space but
then are up against massive regulatory
hurdles and barriers you know a big part
of what we're doing at the chamber is
sharing those resources so you know
again it would be incredibly expensive
for a start-up to hire a team in DC just
to understand the regulatory landscape
let alone try to impact it so if we can
come together and share those resources
and all Bennet and you know have
everyone benefit from the resources that
we have at the chamber I will pay for
itself 10 times over by just having
access to that that information some of
the the there there are a couple
different types of businesses in this
space that have higher regulatory costs
and the exchanges are absolutely at the
top of that list so if you want to be a
crypto exchange today you one have to
register with fencin at the federal
level for your anti money laundering
regulatory requirements and then you
have to receive a license in every
single state that you have customers in
and that's the one thing jesse has been
very vocal about is the state-by-state
regime is it's costly and all the states
are doing differently New York being the
most different and of course he went on
a very vocal tangent calling New York
like the crazy ex-girlfriend that won't
leave you alone and decided to just
leave New York all together and and I
would argue that you you probably can't
be a start-up and operate and in that
space because of how expensive it is and
so there's not there's not this huge
community of
of crypto exchanges and that's really
how innovation and economies grow is by
having lots of different options so you
know it's competition you need
competition that's how you know you two
horses run faster than one on the race
we make each other better by having that
and so these huge barriers to entry are
impacting market formation which is very
you know anti the principles that this
country was founded on yeah I want to
get into some of the regulatory issues
before we start recording we kind of
outlined four of them that I think are
really big and important going into 2020
and beyond and I'll kind of throw them
out there and then you just give me a
here's where we are here's why it's
important and kind of what you guys are
doing or the message that you really
want regulators and legislators to hear
the first is one of everyone's favorite
topics kyc and AML yeah we touched on
them a little bit but this one is very
broad I think because it has application
to pretty much every business that's
touching any sort of transactions what
are you guys seeing around the KYC AML
issues and kind of what are you trying
to accomplish there a lot of things so
we have an AML task force there's an
incredible amount of activity in the AML
space just last year there were 27 bills
that were introduced in the US Congress
that would all call for a study a
different study to look at the AML risk
of virtual currencies 27 different bills
calling for 27 different studies yes a
lot of studying yeah so part of what so
a part of what we've done for our AML
work involves working with Congress
helping coordinate those efforts and
also to bring balance to the
conversation so again yes there are AML
risk and we should understand the risk
but we also need to understand the
benefits so anytime you put together a
pro and a con list you don't just list
cons you always list the pro so it's
amazing how much you have to remind
people to do that but ensuring that you
know Congress has those types of tools
and impacting those conversations and
then helping steer well
slative language that's gonna impact in
all programs for this space over at
fencing
they issued guidance in May of 2019
saying that the funds transfer and
travel rules apply to convertible
virtual currencies and this is something
that is going to impact what's called
vast virtual asset service providers so
hold on let's back up for a second so KY
caml is one component of it and I think
that that's probably the top of mind for
most of the legislators and regulators
just because it's really easy to wrap
your head around right it's just
hey there's money laundering we want to
stop money laundering like this is all
bad stuff right I think your point is
okay yes there is definitely concerns
and risks there we should understand
what those are but virtual currencies
Bitcoin Libre what you know central bank
digital currencies whatever they also
provide some benefits let's look at this
holistically and then make decisions how
do we go right and not only that so if
ensign was actually the first government
organization to issue any guidance
around virtual currency in 2013 it's
prettier and so they actually have
provided a great degree of clarity on
how these laws impact this space but
Congress is is a separate you know
policymaking body and they want to make
sure that we're addressing these risk
and part of what we've even done is gone
to Congress and say look we don't
actually need new laws because fencin
has the jurisdiction they need and it
works and companies for many years have
been building their AML compliance
programs based on the existing law so
changing them today would be very costly
and expensive and disruptive and by the
way I don't know if that's actually got
helfen said so part of that is also
making sure that Treasury understands
what Congress is wanting to do and
making sure that what they're trying to
do is coordinated is actually helpful
yeah make sure they're communicating
with each other right okay so that
that's the AML and kyc world then
there's this travel rule explain like
what exactly that is so the funds travel
and the funds transfer rules fencin this
year came out and said that it applies
to convertible virtual currency
transactions so what that essentially
what it means is it's requiring ident
at both sides of the transaction okay so
if I want to transact Bitcoin or any
other virtual currency kind of an air
quotes they're saying that a business
needs to know who I am and who you are
if I'm gonna transfer you anything okay
that would require them to then conduct
that KYC raml at some point on both
sides of the transaction they know which
is not exactly how it works okay why not
because you don't need identity to send
crypto you just need a public in the
private key can the public key be the
identity oh no no that they want PII
personally identifiable information and
so there was um I'm going to forget who
came on it'll come to me in a second but
they were talking a lot about how we
have essentially through things like the
Patriot Act and other legislation in the
past we've essentially empowered the
banking service to become surveillance
right and they are very very in tune
with who you are what you're doing with
your money who you're transacting with
where you go what you buy right very
much the first line of defense for law
enforcement absolutely absolutely and so
in order for you to retain your privacy
you essentially can't use the financial
system right because of these rules and
laws so how do you think about the
balance between law enforcement needs to
be able to get information at certain
times right and do and do their job but
also at the same time there are
individual rights and privacy as a
default etc that an individual should
enjoy based on what America has been
built on so how do we balance it it's a
very very delicate balance and it's
something we spend a lot of time
thinking about I first and foremost we
don't want to regulate the technology
you want to regulate the the
applications you know companies that are
building applications on the technology
we don't want to impact the growth and
the innovation of this technology but
also we want rules and regulations to
take into account the unique
of this technology so it works so
businesses can grow and be successful I
with this particular issue and I wish
you it's very much looks like the law is
that and the rules that have been
applied to banks and that's what they're
used to
so the scripted stuff is very different
and and our argument is as well the
industry should work together with the
regulator to create a rule that reflects
how the technology works and only
through that process will we be able to
meet the spirit of what you're trying to
accomplish so together as an industry
and and the regulator's being able to
make sure that it takes into account how
this technology works you'll actually
get better rules and regulations and how
it's currently written is it is
concerning what is the impact if it kind
of stays how it is now right like what
is the negative impact to either
companies or the industry so well
companies could be out of compliance so
if a company takes a stand hey I'm not
going to invade the privacy of my users
and get this information they then would
be out of compliance and actions yeah
which would destroy the business yep and
so it's a pretty kerb precarious
position to be put in as a company and
the privacy of your users or deal with
the US government it's not just the US
government this is actually a
requirement from fat F which is the
internet who sets the standards for AML
internationally so all governments are
around the world are having to implement
their own version of the funds travel
and the funds transfer rules and so this
is not actually well talked about in
this space there's a lot of people that
don't that probably don't know that one
these rules have already been issued and
the way that that companies are able to
send and receive transactions is going
to be fundamentally changed by this and
the industry has been given a year to
implement it and we're within that we're
still within that year timeframe so a
AML is
one of the top issues that we are
working on at the chamber first and
foremost we want to make sure our
members really all all companies in this
space have the tools and the resources
to be in compliance with these laws
because an enforcement action would be
incredibly damaging not only to that
business but it'd be a big black eye to
the this entire industry and then work
with the regulators to make sure that as
we are putting together anti-money
laundering protections and the crypto
space that we're doing so in a way that
is not hindering the the innovation the
growth of boxing networks got it that
makes sense
tokens there's a whole rabbit hole of
this to so much to do so some of the
issues around tokens first and foremost
is just how do you define the tokens
right and this is I think we're like the
token taxonomy Act and comes in how are
you guys thinking about that right now
so in the token space we have a group
called the the token alliance it's a
working group that we established over
two years ago now token alliance the
token alliance feels like Power Rangers
like we have a couple former regulators
who are co-chairs of that we have Paul
Atkins he's a former SEC Commissioner
and Jim Newsome who's a former CFTC
chairman and then we just recently
brought Chris Giancarlo the most recent
CFTC Chairman onto our advisory board as
well but the token alliance was was
brought together in a moment where we
have a lot of regulatory uncertainty we
have over 400 individuals that
participate in that in this group and
they've issued a series of guidelines
and considerations while we have
regulatory uncertainty so it's our way
of self regulation it's a step toward
self regulation and it's the industry
coming forward and putting together what
they think the consideration should be
without having the clarity from the SEC
and from regulators it is quite amazing
that several years you know into this we
were still we still don't have
Commission and binding guidance from the
SEC on how to apply the how we test to
digital assets
and you have you know essentially
they're picking winners and losers where
they have said in public speeches and
statements that Bitcoin and eath are not
securities but basically everything else
like question mark we're not really we
don't have binding guidance so that you
know 100 percent legal clarity and so
for regulated companies to get into this
space they can't take a good non-binding
speech it's not gonna pass the the legal
team's check marks to be able to do
really meaningful stuff in this space so
it's holding back innovation in a big
way the easiest thing would be if the
SEC issued actual guidance on this and
they they're not going to at least note
under the current leadership so that's
why you now have all these efforts
happening and Congress someone who
worked in Congress I will tell you you
go to Congress as an absolute last
resort only about 2% of legislation
that's ever introduced will become law
it is a very hard process to get through
through the legal process but that's
where we are and it's great that we have
a number of members of Congress that are
weighing and that are trying to provide
solutions to make sure the industry has
the clarity they need in the securities
laws and how and to clarify the
jurisdiction of digital assets that's
one part of it but also other issues
around tokens that we're seeing since
Facebook's launch of the Liebherr
Association the House Financial Services
Committee has made it one of their
biggest priorities to oversee that
process and so they've brought in Mark
Zuckerberg and David Marcus I've had a
number of hearings and what came out of
that is a couple of pieces of
legislation they introduced the manage
stable coins or Securities Act and the
associated listing prohibition bill and
then this wonderful work of art called a
key big tech out of Finance Act and the
one we're really focused on is this
managed stable coin bill which would
consider certain types of stable coins
as securities and we call that in a band
because if they are treated as
securities they would not be able to be
used as their intended purpose as a
payment mechanism at the chamber we have
over eleven companies that have issued
stable coins and putting the
and quotes so we probably are the
largest staple coin stakeholder in the
world because we represent so many of
these companies so are you putting it in
quotes because they're not so stable
sometimes well how do we define you know
I'm actually putting it in quote well
they they're not always stable even just
they can go up and down by a few basis
points but we what is the definite we've
been arguing the definition of a stable
coin in a managed table coin and what
exactly does that mean and which ones
are going to be in this film which ones
are not within the definitions of this
though either way it's a bad piece of
legislation for this ecosystem and we
don't want to see it go forward but at
the very end of the year last year we
got some information that it was moving
forward for a markup and it was going to
be added to the calendar and that means
it's actually moving through the
legislative process and it was really
the first time in the history of the
crypto space that we had a bill that we
were against that was moving in such a
way and it would really destroy certain
business models and applications for our
space so we had a lot of fun that the
last couple weeks of the the year we
brought a bunch of those companies to DC
we met with these different offices and
ultimately it got pulled and it didn't
go forward for the markup so we played a
role in preventing that from moving
forward but we are expecting to see it
on a calendar later this year but
Congress's oversight in response to
Facebook is something that needs to be
taken incredibly seriously because they
do have concerns and I would say these
are legitimate concerns but again we
want to make sure that the industry's
voice is taken into consideration to
make sure that these laws are helping
support innovation and not just banning
it for all the wrong reasons because
we're afraid of better because we don't
understand it yeah speaking of kind of
innovation and government's the central
bank digital currencies yeah it seems
like there's central bankers around the
world and we'll get to one of the the
most infamous ones in a second but they
saw oh this Bitcoin thing
who cares like these random people on
the internet have no chance of creating
money that would ever threaten our a
kind of our world or our kingdom then
Mark Zuckerberg Facebook and about 30
other companies come out with Libra and
then it like shook them awake and they
said honestly these people have two
billion people they actually have more
people than we usually have using our
currencies if they create a digital
currency and give it a 2 billion people
that is a massive threat to what we have
done as a central bank over you know a
lot of years where are they now and how
do you guys think about them creating
competing digital currencies at the
central bank level them trying to
regulate out competition from private
companies right like there's a bunch of
different paths that they can pursue
here how do you guys kind of evaluate
the landscape and then what are you guys
doing there or what would you like to
see be done around these central bank
digital currencies so according to the
Bank of International Settlements over
70% of central banks that are members of
the BIS are either interested exploring
or building a central bank digital
currencies so that's that's pretty
amazing to think that the most powerful
financial institutions in the world are
exploring blockchain technology on one
side that's pretty exciting on the other
side like how are they gonna do that and
how is that going to impact the the
crypto space so it's where we're
following those trends and I think the
one that's probably the most furthest
along is China and the People's Bank of
China has been looking at blockchain and
central bank digital currency for over
five maybe six years and they have built
a massive platform
I think you've talked about it on this
podcast before but what's really
unbelievable is they've filed over 80
patent applications on their central
bank digital currency project it is
massive is a huge investment is a big
strategic move for the country as a
whole and I think that's gonna be a very
important thing for everyone to
understand because that can impact
monetary policy in the financial system
globally so it was actually dovey wayne
who you've had on here who wrote an up
talking about the the magnitude of this
project and she mentioned these patents
so I sent that article to our patent
attorneys outside Council that we use
and said hey have you looked at these
and they're like no we can't find them
and Dobby had to actually show us how to
go find them in the system because they
were obscured under all of these
separate names but we found them we
found 84 we have translated them into
English and we've been studying them
over the past couple of months and we'll
be publishing in this cachet we'll be
making it available one so everybody can
can can learn what what we've learned
but - we think it's important that the
Fed understands that - and we think the
you know these are patents in China that
the People's Bank of China for just
their central bank digital currency
project so we'll be releasing that in
the next couple weeks will share our
findings and our thoughts on it and
making them available in the English
language but one thing that we have been
advocating at the chamber of digital
commerce specific to the United States
is having a national action plan for
blockchain we think the United States
should be taking this technology
incredibly serious as serious as we've
taken other advanced technologies like
the internet and 5g and AI and we think
you know whatever countries are at the
forefront of this are going to benefit
greatly and we selfishly want the u.s.
to benefit from that but also from a
regulatory perspective these efforts
need to be better coordinated and one of
the bigger challenges that we have is
you have so many different regulatory
agencies with different types of
jurisdiction you know the SEC you know
once you know everything to be a
security the CFTC as are considering
these tokens commodities you have the
IRS
that taxes the most property fence and
us regulating them as currency there's
there's really no holistic view or a lot
of reason or sense to to how the
regulatory frameworks are moving forward
so having a coordinated strategy I think
it's gonna be incredibly important
especially for small businesses that
don't have unlimited resources to figure
this out and have teams of people you
know going to all these different
regulatory authorities to being sure
they're in compliance with all these
different offices there should be a
central coordinator and that's a big
part of our national action plan for
blockchain but also making sure our
government is at the forefront of this
technology because it's going to be
important for our economy and
international security should the dollar
get digitized it already is is it yeah I
mean what digital I mean there are
digital banking services and and we use
money digital digitally already I should
the Fed issue a dollar on a blockchain
that's something that Christian Carlow
has called for aka crypto dad he's
recently joined our board of advisers
that's a big passion project for him and
if you talked to him he thinks it's the
most important thing to ensure the
United States dollar remains the world
reserve currency for another generation
that this is an issue of art our
dominance worldwide and by having the
Fed issue a central bank digital
currency is the way to preserve that
over time I completely agree with them
if you're trying to optimize for the
dollar to be the global reserve currency
for the foreseeable future if you do not
tokenize it or digitize it on a
blockchain you will in essence shoot
yourself in the foot we have you have to
be a technical leader to be a leader and
anything else
there's this interview from June 2018
with mr. Agustin Karstens who's at the
bank of International Settlement and
there's four specific quotes that I want
to pull from this interview it's a gem
of a speech if you have not looked at
this speech it's titled my message to
young people stop trying to create money
is everything you could ever wish and
hope for from a central bank and the
reason I want to pull these four quotes
is I think it gives a great
understanding and insight into how some
of these people think and so when I say
the quote I just want you to give me
your kind of immediate thoughts and
reactions the first is quote it is
therefore the duty of central bankers to
ensure that purchasing power is
maintained moreover there has to be a
guarantee that money is able to fulfill
the important role in the economic
system and that monetary policy can help
growth and income distribution so ensure
purchasing power is maintained what does
that mean it means inflation is not
happening so your purchasing power is
declining
every time you print more money and
that's literally what these banks are
doing so if that's really the priority
it's a little counter to counter
intuitive well if their duty is to
ensure that purchasing power is
maintained they failed rightly it's one
of my favorite things to explain to
institutional investors right because
they don't think about kind of inflation
and monetary supply and although I say
the US dollar has lost value every
single year for the last 100 years
every single year and it's actually it's
quite it's a hidden tax and it's quite
sad because a lot of people don't
understand it and it is maleeh robbing
people of their their savings and from
the people who need it the most you know
the it's really the poor people it's the
middle class the lower middle class that
are mostly impacted by this and it's one
of the reasons why I got into this space
is to fight for those people that we
really do deserve something better and
we deserve sound money for sure I
completely agree and
in terms of income distribution right so
it says there has to be a guarantee that
money is able to fulfill its important
role in the economic system and that
monetary policy can help growth an
income distribution agree disagree so
the income distribution piece is is
interesting I as a free-market
capitalist that really does not resonate
with my economic principles and I don't
you know I see that more as a socialist
view to economics which is certainly not
one that I think represents the values
of the United States which is
interesting because he's representing
the global central bank set and I'm not
sure if that really is the right
approach for every single member of the
Bank of International Settlements well
that that's a theoretical argument right
I would just go to the practical
argument that says if that is the goal
it obviously hasn't worked again because
there's the highest level of income
inequality we've ever seen that's right
and so yeah theoretically they can want
income distribution or equal income
distribution but they're not getting it
yeah but by printing more money through
quantitative easing or you know other
programs you you are distributing income
you're injecting money into the system
they're controlling where those those
injections are going so it is impacting
the financial system and it is impacting
who has access to that money first which
is not really the people who need it
which is where the kind of funny thing
with you know Ben Bernanke as the
helicopter money just jump dropping
money out of helicopters I'll still a
quote from somebody I can't remember who
said it but the original airdrop thing
was done Wilson that said that we're
just kind of hilarious but yeah it's
that the Fed does have it in central
banks have an incredible power in terms
of who has access to that money first
and if we're really trying to empower
the economy you know how do you
effectively do that and we can certainly
spend a lot of times you're criticizing
these programs ii quote from mr.
Carson's I am concerned by the pace of
technological progress
principle it's a positive thing but when
innovation hurdles ahead it can be
destructive for workers in particular
the challenge lies in using innovation
to our advantage while containing the
damage it causes here I'm thinking for
example of the impact of information
technology and Finance FinTech on say
the business models and ultimately the
stability of banks and other financial
institutions he's essentially talking
about disruption yeah right and he's
concerned that disruption can occur by
applying quote information technology in
finance or this thin tech it's kind of
pointed disruption right well the it's
the whole point of innovate why do
people innovate why does innovate why
does innovation happen if people see a
more effective a better way to do
something they see a problem with the
system you're gonna have people who step
forward and propose something different
to fix those issues innovation is how we
improve ourselves so to take such a
negative step on innovation is it really
baffles me because you would think the
people at the very top of that hierarchy
would say yes please give us all your
best ideas how can we be better how can
we improve and they're discouraging that
which is I think what will ultimately
not play well for them yeah well we'll
see the third quote quote it is
important to draw a clear distinction
between the underlying technology such
as blockchain and crypto currencies per
say the technology may have useful
applications but producing money is not
one of them end quote
so it was Aristotle who first defined
the characteristics of money
he said money has to be divisible
portable divisible and have intrinsic
value central bank's later
redefined what money is to be a unit of
account and means a payment or a store a
value so there is a lot of debate about
what is money and I think that's one of
the most exciting things that's
happening on the global stage where
people are really starting to question
how
this work and the more people educate
themselves on the monetary system I
think will actually get to better
outcomes because I do think there's a
lot of challenges with these systems I
don't think the system works for
everybody
and I do think blockchain technology is
gonna play a huge role and improving our
financial and our monetary system in a
very positive way so I think it's
important and talk about what money is
you know Bitcoin does have challenges in
terms of being a method of payment
people aren't really using it as a
method of payment I would argue it's
actually the government's fault because
we tax it as property therefore it
cannot behave as as money that they did
the same thing with gold and silver so
you know gold and silver was actually
what was outlined in the Constitution to
be used as money and because they tax it
as property and as a commodity you have
a capital gains or a loss on every
single transaction which just makes it
completely unfeasible for people to use
in their daily lives so I think the
government has actually driven that
behavior and it's possible virtual
currencies in cryptocurrencies would you
know potentially operate as a method of
payment if we had the proper rules and
regulations that allowed for that use
case it's funny how Aristotle was a way
be way ahead of his time yeah sure and
he was right and for thousands and
thousands of years civilizations have
flocked to gold and silver mostly gold
and even just 75 years ago the United
States was on a gold standard that was
you know the Bretton Woods Agreement you
think about it at Britain woods the the
world came together to redefine how the
global monetary system would work
they said gold was going to be priced at
$35 an ounce the US dollar would be the
world reserve currency all other nations
would peg their money to the dollar and
they could legally demand gold from the
US Treasury that was 75 years ago that
was not that long ago and it was just a
couple of years after that it was
impossible to maintain the peg the
entire system completely broke down by
the 80s and we all moved to these
floating exchange rates to what fiat
currency is today so and it is really
quite amazing just to think about how
much them
Theriault system has evolved in just a
few short years and now with all these
advanced technologies whether it's AI or
blockchain the Internet
think about how much more money is gonna
evolve in the future so I think
innovation is exciting and I think it's
really important that central banks
including the Federal Reserve really
understand this because they do play
such a huge role and the way our
economies function and we want to see
and we don't want to see massive
disruptions that's going to be bad for
the people and in order to stay ahead of
that you have to be ahead of these
technological advancements and
blockchain being probably the most
meeting it was important absolutely
the last quote quote central banks are
trusted and that Trust is something they
have built up over decades and for which
there is no substitute right now Trust
is the valuable commodity it is easily
destroyed but winning it takes time
money has become established young
people should use their many talents and
skills for innovation not reinventing
money it's a fallacy to think money can
be created from nothing literally like a
spit-take right there I'm so it's a
fallacy to think money can be created
from nothing I mean that's literally
what central banks do so I'm just I'm
even just confused as to what he's
trying to prove here but to tell young
people that they should not use their
many talents to innovate with money is
just I well let's take this step by step
right so first of all he says central
bank's are trusted which I would argue
that's not even true well then the very
next the very next part of the speech he
says well there was this real
well-respected book that talks about all
the secrecy at the Bank of International
Settlements and of course you know
they're there a lot of the activities at
central banks are not known to the
public and and so if the interesting
what's so cool about about blockchain is
you don't have a trust it's just math
it's algorithms the software just works
like you can you can audit it you can
verify it for yourself you don't need
trust so even this idea
trust it's completely being radically
transformed through innovation and I
think these roles of these central banks
and Manama cowers that be is gonna
change a lot and what the idea of trust
is and how it works we're really pushing
that as a community onto what those
limits are for sure my favorite part is
when he says young people should use
their many talents and skills for
innovation not reinventing money and the
two things I think about is one that
would insinuate that he believes Satoshi
Nakamoto is a young person which maybe
they're older than him right who knows
and then two is I cannot think of a
bigger innovation than reinventing money
if it was an improvement on that money
yeah right and so can you imagine if Tim
Cook just said hey you know young people
we figured out personal computers
personal computers are established there
is no need to innovate we got it like we
would still be stuck using yeah it's
crazy like this this logic what you
would not use this in anything in any
other industry
I personally want to go back to the
Apple computers that had the clear the
colorful design on the back we put one
of those in your backpack yeah and I
remember just awesome what oh uh where
can people find out more about the
chamber and kind of what your your pitch
to them in terms of why it's important
to to support you guys and then become a
member so if you want to be a part of
growing this ecosystem regulation and
policy is one of the biggest barriers to
the adoption of digital assets and
blockchain technology and the chamber of
digital commerce is a dedicated
organization to provide professional
resources to impact positive public
policy a smart public policy for this
space as a non-profit we do not sell any
products or services companies are
invited to be a member of the
organization as a member you have access
to the resources and the benefits that
we provide but you're also contributing
to that the important policy work of the
organization you can check us out
Digital Chamber org and we also host an
annual conference so we'll be holding
the DC blockchain summit the fifth
annual summit on March 11th and 12th at
Georgetown University so most of our
members come in from all over the world
to be a part of that conversation and we
have a really nice academic setting to
have conversations about some of the
most important issues impacting the
space will have different regulators
members of Congress who will come out
and participate in the conversations and
it's a great opportunity to learn but to
also be a part of the the network at the
chamber of digital commerce pretty
compelling I got three questions for you
before I let you go what's the most
important book you've ever read I so the
libertarian Bible Atlas Shrugged would
be my one of my favorites why it really
just kind of takes the the ideas of
capitalism and puts it into to everyday
life and it really challenged a thought
process back then and it's turned it's
it's played a huge role in impacting the
way businesses and policymakers think
about free economics aliens believer or
non-believer yeah absolutely so so when
I worked on Capitol Hill I had the
opportunity to meet a lot of astronauts
you guys can't see if what he's laughing
is that stuff in the corner but a lot of
weird people working in government yeah
but every time I've had the opportunity
to meet anyone who's actually been to
space I always add I actually always ask
them that question and every single one
of them have always said yes
the astronauts always say yes yeah yeah
so my latest research in the alien quest
is there are let me if I remember this
correctly there are 10,000 planets for
every one grain of sand oh my gosh
that's unbelievable
that's Lewis estimate so cool 10,000
planets for every grain of sand and I
think it's like 10 to the 22nd power or
something which is way above my head
the mathematics world but when you think
about that like they gotta exist
absolutely
sorry we're gonna get a we're gonna get
a meter in here and we're gonna put it
on the podcast on the video as to how
funny Joe thinks things are we're just
gonna sound like a good dialing yeah
yeah he's just sitting over there in the
corner just dying laughing
all right you could ask me one question
I end this thing so my question for you
I'm the Bitcoin having what what are you
expecting to see and how are you paying
for that
well I always answer this question now
in a very matter-of-fact way I'm
expecting that the monetary supply of
Bitcoin is gonna go in half yeah yes we
know that so like there's a lot of
people who well there's a lot of people
who like forget like that's an important
thing right like that has to happen if
for some reason there was a bug or
something like if that does not happen
there are major red flags but my
expectation is that the code is going to
execute how it should execute and there
will be having in the supply now the
question that you're getting at is like
what are the ramifications of that
happening and for me I don't think
there's gonna be a lot of change right
in terms of what's happened in the past
and mainly it's because supply and
demand economics haven't changed either
and so if you think about how supply and
demand works is if you change the
incoming supply of an asset right and
all of a sudden it becomes harder or
more expensive to get that asset and
demand stays constant there should be a
gradual rise in price now if you couple
that change with incoming supply with a
drastic increase in demand at some
period of time then there's a massive
increase in price in a very short period
of time I tend to think the latter is
more likely than the former but either
way when you change something so
fundamental in a very basic economic
principle of supply and demand like
there is going to be a movement what I
always call out as well though is like
there are some things that are different
now
right so there's derivative products
allow people to go
or there's a lot more scrutiny on this
thing etc and so it doesn't have to play
out exactly but from a framework
standpoint or a systemic standpoint
supply and demand economics still apply
right and so this whole idea of like is
it priced in is it not priced in like
well like who cares all I know is that
supply demand economics are valid and
there is no one on the planet that's
gonna convince me that if you change the
supply of something whether that is
total supply or also incoming supply
that there is not a change in the price
and of course there is yeah and so look
we're gonna go through this in five
months there's gonna be a bunch of
debate over the next five months I'm not
gonna participate in any of it and we'll
see about 18 months afterwards or gonna
end up 2021 we'll see who's right yeah
right but to me it's pretty clear so
we'll see yeah it's gonna be a big year
what do you think's gonna happen
I well I think on the demand side we've
seen a ton of scrutiny over this space
and you're now seeing you know heads of
state heads of central banks they're
actively coming out and saying all sorts
of negative things about Bitcoin so is
that gonna impact
demand is that going to change the
dynamics of this having versus the ones
that have happened previously I you know
I think we'll likely see an increase in
price but the price of Bitcoin is so
irrational anyone who says they
understand the price of Bitcoin I think
is just lying cuz there's so many things
that go into it we get a price
prediction from the chamber of digital
hours all right guys I tried I stick to
policy remind us of the URL one more
time people can go find you guys digital
chamber org alright where can people
find you on the internet on Twitter
etcetera
Matt Perry NDC on Twitter through the DC
in there
all right Perry Anne was just taken so
at Perry NDC that's fair
thank you I'm going to do this what
we'll have to do it again later in the
year kind of as things progress but I
think a lot of people really see you
know the important work you guys are
doing so just from all of us thank you
so much for uh for doing this last
year's and you guys you got a lot of
support from from us and other people in
the industry awesome thank you